how did it feel to be back on a Star
Wars set after 30 years you know it it
it might have felt silly to be going
back and playing a character that you
played 40 years ago but it didn't and it
didn't because there was a clear job to
be done there was an extension of the
character that I thought was interesting
and would take the audience to a new
place there was a development in the
character that's rude
doesn't play out on screen but is
referred to in a way that the audience
understands the circumstances that have
been part of Hans history between the
last of the first three and the events
that were following in this one and and
those circumstances in his life have
created changes which are going to
motivate him in different ways than we
might expect so the character has some
surprise to him at this point tell us
about the Millennium Falcon is it the
same as you left it the Millennium
Falcon said it's it's funny because the
the set had actually been dismantled
after the first film it had not been
predicted that the film would be such a
success as it was and so that they had
to recreate it from
from pictures and they did a beautiful
job of rebuilding it and it was very it
was indistinguishable to me from the
original set so it was it was nice to be
back this is the first time you've
worked with JJ Abrams as a director what
is his style and what does he bring to
the filmmaking process his style is you
know intense preparation great
enthusiasm willingness and gives himself
both it gives himself the freedom to
make changes in his expectations
according to what he seasons on the set
he's collaborative he's he is altogether
a consummate master of his craft what do
you think of the newcomers to the
franchise John boyega and Daisy Ridley I
think I think the choices that were made
to cast these parts are our mortal
choices Daisy and John are wonderful in
their parts they're very interesting
people both of them and I think they're
going to have unbelievable future well I
didn't stop being Leia I mean it doesn't
go away it's like a persistent rash no
no but I
I am print I had stayed in character for
the last 35 years I count it from the
last movie but if we count it from the
first it's 40 years
but people identify me with her so much
and I am the custodian of Princess Leia
so I try to keep her fit and ready for
action I were general outfits I know I
haven't changed it because I'm general
because they didn't tell me I was
general until it was too late and then I
was suddenly general and what I have
said though is in terms of being general
or princess even though Princess is kind
of Nellie and it it's something that you
inherit and so it's general is something
that generally you have to rise through
the ranks and so forth
Princess Leia theoretically a princess
would get better clothes not good
hairstyles but better clothes and even
then but still general clothing you've
seen them and those hats if I think that
my hair was bad imagine wearing one of
those iron has she's very focused very
disciplined very passionate committed to
what she does and I have those qualities
but not choose don't laugh at me I do
have those qualities but not I don't
have control over them and I don't have
them as intensely and she's very
organized and I would say maybe I'm not
organized
because she was really the first female
character that and it's not it they're
not the characters in Star Wars are very
human they're not superpower
I mean yes we have the force but you
know if you are very good and you work
very hard Santa will bring you the force
for Christmas no but it doesn't seem
that out of reach you know their
characters you can identify with and
their characters where you feel like
well if they can do that you know I
could do that so you know that she can
do what she can do and she can also do
what she can't do well it was just
amazing to be there I'm older now and I
could pay attention because when you're
young and you're doing those things
you're just moving through your life
like you know you'll be able to reflect
on it they don't tell you that you lose
your memory and that your ability to
reflect is impacted by memory loss
severely so I can pay attention this
time and I can also watch these younger
people you know experience it and and I
wonder if it was like that for me and I
suspect it was you know so that's I
could retrieve my memory through them
and also my daughter is a little part in
it so that was fun to have my daughter
around
I think they'll love it they go and they
go in to love it so what if you think
can happen with something like that
you're you're gonna be disappointed no
matter what you know because you're
going in thinking it'll be some
life-changing experience but if you go
into the movie just to you know
reacquaint yourself with some old
friends and get into these situations
that we're incredibly exciting and now
familiar they'll just have a really good
time I think because it'll be
reminiscent and because it's new and we
have some new folks and I think they'll
love it
JJ's awesome he is incredible infectious
enthusiasm he's a huge fan of Star Wars
and which was I think daunting for him
because he grew up watching the movies
as well so how are you gonna so he had
that kind of pressure but you never saw
that and he's very confident and he
learned everyone's name I'm not kidding
even my dog's name but then my dog is
very famous he just just he has high
verbal acuity which I appreciate
enormously he's fun to listen to and
even though he's younger than I am by
like an hour that feels more like 10
years he has a lot of the same sort of
media references he he knows movies he
knows music you know and he loves his
job so it's a pleasure to watch anybody
enjoy what they're doing when did it hit
you that you were actually directing
this movie what was the moment there was
there's so many baby steps so it's hard
to it's hard to figure out where you
know there wasn't one sort of threshold
crossing it was a lot of
decisions and moments and stages along
the way but I guess that the honest
answer is when we were in Abu Dhabi and
all the prep had come to this moment
when the crew was all there the cameras
and the lights were all set up Daisy
Ridley was sitting down for her first
take and I I thought oh here we are
we figured out what the set would look
like what her speeder would be like what
her hair design was going to be how the
wardrobe was going to look where and
when and how and what lens we were going
to shoot this moment and all the prep
brought us to this moment we were
actually doing it and I guess it was
that first day of actually filming in
125 degree heat in the middle of this
desert that that really felt like we
were making a movie as a lifelong fan
what were the Star Wars elements that
you needed to make sure you had in this
film to satisfy the fans
well Larry Kasdan and I we started
talking about what we wanted to do in
this movie it was more about a feeling
than any kind of list of things that we
wanted to include but among those things
in that in that feeling were elements of
light versus dark elements of either
action or certain specific things
whether it's ships or locations that
felt like the spirit of Star Wars and
people have been trying to copy what
George Lucas created since he created
Star Wars and we were lucky enough to
actually inherit Star Wars this to be
the next chapter of the saga which meant
we were allowed to actually say well I
you know I'd love to see lightsabers and
you know how was this academic a Star
Wars movie that lightsabers
what's a Star Wars movie without the
next wing or a TIE fighter or a Star
Destroyer and you can sort of list these
things and someone I work with was
saying how Star Wars is a bit like a
Western where there are certain tenants
it's a different story a different world
a different moral a different narrative
but probably have horses it's probably
have cowboys might be some Native
Americans probably be a saloon there
might be a bank there might be
stagecoach there are just certain things
good guys bad guys you know it's it's it
was a little bit like needing to know
okay if we're if we're telling a story
in this genre in this Star Wars genre
what are certain things that feel like
essential elements but once we had those
things everything was serving the story
who would these new characters who are
we meeting we've never met before what
is their story why is it relevant why
are we telling a story at all in this in
this universe and that was I think the
most fun we had what did you how did you
go about ensuring that the movie would
be relatable to a whole new generation
of fans well the the key to this movie
was not any of the accoutrements or
props or ships or locales it was all
about who is the story about and when
Larry Kasdan and I began writing the
script that was the fundamental question
we would make ourselves tell each other
the story you know this is a story about
a young woman who this story about a
young man who like tell the story and
it's amazing how that is sort of a
litmus test for something that either
works or not because you can't say it's
a story about really cool gadgets it's a
story about spaceships that flood none
of that will work it's a story about
someone who it's it's about the heart
and soul of the characters so that was
the thing that we focused on trying to
figure out what makes the story
compelling for us and hope that if we
can look each other in the eye and say I
love that that really works that's
that's getting me excited then other
people might feel it talked about the
importance of music in the film when I
look at the list of things um when I
think of the things that that George
Lucas did and and got right got
perfectly in that first movie it is so
long and stunning to think of of those
things but nothing on that list is more
important than the music that's not to
say there aren't things that are as
important but it's not more important
and what John Williams did his gift to
Star Wars and to fans
it is you can't oversell the importance
of what he does and to know that he was
coming back to create a score for the
force awakens was as exciting as any
other aspect of working on this movie
from the very first discussion I had
with Kathy Kennedy to be on the stage
when John Williams conducted the main
titles which of course is familiar to
everyone who knows Star Wars that was
incredible but then to watch him conduct
and hear the orchestra play so
beautifully the end title is the almost
eight minute long end titles what was
incredible about that was it starts the
way it always starts but then it goes
into it dovetails into these themes
Ray's theme the resistance theme kylo
ren's theme these incredible cues that
we had become accustomed to over the
months of doing post-production that
were so beautiful and soaring and
emotional and powerful and somehow
perfectly integrated with the score and
the music that we know the forest theme
latest thing he just like no one else is
able to take what we know and do
something brand new and somehow allow
them to co-exist and I realize that's
what we were trying to do all along
you